[ Crowd chanting ]
THE GONDON
HAGEL WITH HIM.T'S KEPT OUT BY
VASILEVSKIY.
GIORDANO.
NYLANDER AGAIN WITH A SHOT
THE QUICK RELEASE BUT AS
VASILEVSKIY SO OFTEN DOES
KUCHERD
HERE'S THE STAMKN UP TO
THE GOT A LITTLE BIT TO HIS
LEFT SKATE SO HE HAD T HAD SOMWS
THEY WERE SHORTHANDED DURING
THE REGN.
HERE'S HED BY CAMPBELL.NE.
MIKHEYEV.
WHAT A GOAL MAN FONT.
MIKHEYEV IN FRONT.
HE GETS A PIECE OF THIS,
HIGHEST SCORING FOURTH LINE
IN THE NHL THIS YEAR.
HZING AND IT'S
TRANSITION A AU SEE JASON
SPEZZA, WHO'S THEEF.
>> Chris: LEAFS WER 64 SECONDS.
>> Craig: THE BATTLES ON THE
DR NYLANDER'S GOT IT.
TIME-OUT
WELL SPENT.
THAT'S JUST PERFECT
EXECUTION.
FMAN.
[ Crowd din ]
HERE'S KAMPF RACING IN!
CAMPBELL MAKES A GREAT
REACTION TO POINT TRYING TO
GET THAT REBOUND.
WATCH MAROV, HEDMAN.
HERE'S A BLAST TH URGENCY ON TH.
LIGHTNING POWER PLAY.
>> Craig:
MATTHEWS, AWAY.
HE'LL SWING IT.
MORGANY BY MORGAN
RIELLY?
STAMKOS.
KEPT IN BY RIELLY.
AUSTON MATTHEWS BEHAGAINO MONTRL
FOR THE FUNERAL TOMORROW. SCOOPT
GIORDANO.
THERE'S HE SENT IT
WIDE.
ANYTHING YOU'RE SEEING IN
PARTIC
KASE WILL DUMP IT IN.TTA'S GOIN.
THE PUCK BOUNCES OVER THE
STICK OF VASILEVSKIY.
ANOTHER FRUSTRATING MOMENT
ENGVALL, BACK TO GOING TO
BE -- WOW!
CAN YOUING WIDE
THERE.
JON COOPER LIKES TO USE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT.
I THINK THAT